the last talk of today oh my goodness
and of the whole conference so um I have
the last person to introduce today he's
going to talk about ranking tennis
players with beian modeling I am very
intrigued by this so let's welcome to
the stage Francesco
[Applause]
brelli thank you
right good morning everyone thank you
for attending um I want to talk about uh
how we can use Vision inference to
challenge the status quo of tennis
systems um why this do even exist so I'm
a data scientist and I play tennis
competitively for 12 years as a kid I
still follow a lot the tennis world and
what happens so I had a spare weekend
and I thought it was a fun time to spend
when it's raining in Berlin so that's
how it started um
so topic agenda of the today I'm the
last guy standing between you and
enjoying the beautiful uh day in
Amsterdam so let's get to work uh we'll
start about uh what's what's happening
with the current system and what's wrong
with that if anything is wrong with that
uh then there is a broadly ter model
that also some other speaker spoke about
during the the event and finally we get
our hands dirty implementing that in PC
so hopefully you learn about some tricks
and tips about that then we finally do
ranking and we'll compare how these
systems work and finally some other
application and extension that one can
reason
about okay by show an how many of you
know how 10is system ranking system
works not many people so let's start
from that um it's a very simple system
it's Point based um every week there is
a
tournament Players randomly match with
each other kind of randomly uh given by
the ranking and who wins go to the next
round when you lose depending on the
round you got to you got some points and
at the end of of the week the points
updates and the ranking updates and
those points are then used for the next
week and these points are uh kept for 52
weeks so it's a here rolling uh system
so is a b maybe okay so it we can say
that it has a few flows um so it's round
base so depending when you lose you get
the points it's not opponent base and
for example chess you have L ratings and
it's opponent base so if you beat War
number one in the first round uh you
will get more points and beating word
100 Word number 100 or something uh
here's not the case and you can see
these are the points awarded in
Wimbledon so depending on where you get
then you got some points and that's it
uh it's also can be a number game since
the points some with what you have uh
you here there's an example of two
players that
it's rank number four and rank number
eight and the win rate is better for
rank number eight but he played less
matches due to injuries and so it's as a
lower ranking um surf surfaces are
interchangeable so the points that you
get in one
surface are used basically for
everything and doesn't matter which
tournament is going to to happen next
week and this is bad in a way because
there are some Surface Specialist that
like a lot playing some surface but they
don't basically play so others and there
are some quotes here like I don't want
to play on this clay surface or grasses
for golf players which is reasonable but
still and they're also mandatory events
so they cannot keep their tournaments um
finally last week points count as last
year um there is no rency
Concept in in the points um I hope I
don't lose anybody yet but sum up the
system is uh some of the performance in
the last 52 weeks rolling and these
points are used as I mentioned to enter
the next uh week tournament but also to
give seed to the people so what you
would expect is that um War number one
and War number two don't uh challenge
each other until the final
and so if we have a let's say bias
ranking you would have you would keep
better player out of a tournament that
they would deserve to attend and you
would also make stronger player match
each other sooner in a tournament and we
don't want that so we can say that also
as a fun what I would like to see is
that uh these features first of all but
also some predictive power so so uh
let's say I want to know who is the best
player at the moment uh in every uh
point in time and I would expect that
war number one has probability like
higher probability of beting War number
three than War number two and so on and
so forth so giving some predictive power
to the
matches okay so let's go with some
Theory it's not a lot of theory but
still uh I'm the model that will help us
to address these challenges it's called
Brad lary which is a probabilistic model
for per comparison uh which are the
matches and in tennis these are spars we
don't see every single uh pair we have a
very spars set
and the assumption is that the
probability of one player to beat
another player is is based on um um
function of their abilities which we
don't know which are Theta and th J it's
logistic regression after all so the
probability of player I beating player J
is given by the logistic of the
difference of their
abilities if nobody if somebody didn't
see a logistic regression before you
take a real value and you mop it into 01
which we will interpret as a probability
so the example here uh we have Theta 1
and Theta 2 and the difference is some
somewhere in between you mop it and you
got the probability of player one
meeting player two of
92% um yeah what we interesting
interested in learning are their latent
abilities and this model will serve us
also
to model their abilities in different
ways uh that given some assumptions and
yeah um so let's start with what we need
to build such a model some data uh where
the come from it's called this amazing
GitHub rapple by Jeff sakman is the real
hero of the story it's a very well
maintained data set please go help him
if you can if you're interested to uh I
just focus on two years like his data
set is from the beginning of time
basically uh I'm also excluding like
team events National events that players
most of the time don't really care about
uh so they not be so much informative
and also I'm excluding players that have
less than 10 matches in two years and we
are left with 200 players
um okay let's say we have a function to
load the data from 2021 to today uh we
have 6,000 matches if we check how the
table is something like that we have
tournament name uh the date of the
tournament which is the same for every
match it's not the date of the match uh
the surface they played in we have three
surfaces clay hard and grass um who won
who lost and the respective
ranking okay uh this is I we the last
premise slide what we need to know um I
am basically doing um cross validation
because a single tournament will not be
very indicative of what we do uh I'm
treating this as as if would do with a
Time serious validation so I have
training on 52 weeks and forecasting for
the for following uh tournament or
following week okay so I start from a
baseline somebody yesterday mentioned
baselines are important so let's start
from there we have a ranking as I
mentioned we cannot say that it has some
predictive power and so we will assume
that the better ranking player will win
the
match and let's do that in pandas we
first create a will uh column which is
called best rank win and it's if the
winner rank is lower than the loser rank
then that's the case we select only the
uh test period which since we have 52
weeks of training will discard uh first
here we select the column we take them
mean and it's not even 62% and is good
maybe I mean it's not that far from a CO
flip and since a two player match then I
don't know uh but this is to be expected
there are a lot of upset in tennis you
cannot expect that war number one wins
every single match right uh because
that's never the case and so there are a
lot of upsets every week okay so how
many people used PMC or some beon
framework
before okay less than
expected okay uh very short summary
about p see it's a probability
programming framework it's based on a
tensor Library called penser which
provides automatic
differentiation and
compilation and PC provides all the
distributions and all the sampling
methods that one needs in these cases um
so this is there are some PC developers
that maybe will get angry at me uh I
hope not okay so so how do you work with
PMC you while import a module and then
you build the model entering the context
manager uh which weas as base model so
now we are starting to address all the
issues that I mentioned and this model
will just address the thing the the fact
that it can be a number game and it's
it's not opponent based so these These
are what we'll solve at the end of the
slide uh we enter the context and then
we create we assign an X and A Y which
are the X to train and the target
variable uh and I'm using this mutable
data object which we'll see why in the
future um and then you can slize this uh
Tor you as you would with nonp array so
I'm selecting the First Column of the X
and second column and the x is the
indexes of the players in a match so we
have player index 63 against player 47
and since in our table player one was
always winning we have that Y is always
one that that's how it's built um then
we need some priors so I'm creating two
priors one is for the mean of the
ability and we have one for every player
so you can see that um it's a normal
distribution centered zero Sigma one we
don't have much information and there is
shape equal number of players so we have
one of these for for every player and
then we have one single standard
deviation which kind of hierarchical
model uh
Direction um and then we multiply this
together and we get the pro the player
the single player ability and then uh
these two um variables one is PM
deterministic what does it mean it means
that in the sampling uh uh the the
engine will keep track of this variable
and then so you can imagine as player
ability is a tensor of shape the number
of players uh in each index there is
such player ability and then when in the
next line we slice with the index we
select that player ability and we take
the difference and this is also
deterministic variable but we don't care
about the Delta um so basically I'm not
tracking that
and finally the the as we saw in the
model the Delta between the abilities is
the input to the logistic function which
we are tracking with the the terministic
and this probability is fed into a beri
distribution so what the intuition is
since the outputs are always one you
would imagine that the model tried to
push this probability as high as one as
it can all the time uh sorry as large as
it can because
then the output of the BR of the
logistic will be as close as one as
possible um okay so this is how the
model is built um and then we need to
fit the model right so we don't have the
do Feit as in second learn uh thas would
say that there is a another inference
magic button uh so again we enter the mo
the context uh with the name we gave to
the model and then
there is the do samp do sample function
which takes a bunch of parameters which
probably need a talk on its own um but
you can decide which sampler to use and
which are the every every parameter of
the sampler and so on uh how many chains
and how many samples you want um you do
that and then you wait right it's like
okay sampling takes time uh you can move
it to GP if you want it takes time
usually so you Feit the model and then
what you get is some posterior Trace um
sorry I didn't mention that uh I'm
saving the trace which is not just the
fit model but you also have some other
information so you take the trace and
it's a rvds object which contain the
posterior the and the sample statistics
um which are some statistic which give
you an indication if the model converged
well if there were issues with the model
if anything went wrong and so on uh and
then it's also to keep track of some
some of the data uh what's in the
posterior so everything we tracked so
player ability uh the means and the
probabilities are in the posterior so
this will be number of samples time
number of chains for each variable uh
and to give you an example these are the
traces of the posterior of the top 10
players for a single sampling time for
single feet and it looks quite well
normal distributed and you can see there
is a player two couple of players that
are distance from the others and then
there is a lot of intersection between
other players ability um
cool we need to predict so for a lot of
time MC has been quite a pain in the to
predict on new data now it's because
very simple um so if you remember we
when we uh introduced the the data was a
multiple object so what we just do is
okay we enter the context again and then
we set data uh so we set our x to the
test data and then why we don't care
because that's what our Target uh so
it's empty array or something and
instead of sampling we do sample
posterior predic which is the analogous
of do predict in C learn
and we can also decide what what
variable to trace with VAR names uh
what's in here it's
a it's arit inference data object
contains some posterior predictive which
are the results basically and some data
and for each result you have a
distribution which is cool okay nice we
back test these and it's half perc point
above the Baseline so that's good enough
okay fair everybody's laughing but at
least it has the two two of the four uh
problems that he wanted to address okay
so let's go a slightly more comp complex
model to address them so I call this
model ability by surface with Decay
because I didn't have time to show like
every single step so I put them together
um you enter a new context called Model
you again you have the data X and Y
and X is basically your array and the
First Column second column are the
indexes of the players and then you have
the index of the surface and then you
have sample weights which is very
similar to what we will do in a psychic
learn model and it's a Decay function so
the last week weight is 100% one week
ago 99 and so on decaying until 52 weeks
ago uh so that the model will give more
importance to the most recent weeks uh
this block is exactly the same of the
other model so nothing new here and now
we are
introducing the same shape the same uh
concept but we have a surface factor for
player for surface so it's a lot of more
parameters now um and finally we
combined the differences between like
what I'll call the core ability which is
the base Delta and the difference of the
surface specific ability so basically we
are giving a a bonus for a surface for
each player uh if they deserve to uh
finally we fit that into the logistic we
got the probability uh okay now how do
we use the sample weight that like primc
doesn't have a out of the box way to do
that so
basically what the S sampler does is it
let me pass this term it's optimize for
the log likelihood the entire system and
so we create our our custom log
likelihood and we can do that with PC
potential um so we multiply element wise
the beri results times the weights and
now last week will count as ones and
previous week will count less and less
and less and then what will the sampler
will optimize is this this error uh
which is yeah error name there we do the
same Fe the the model we check that
everything converges well no issues blah
blah blah and then uh finally we run the
back test and it's 1.5 above Baseline
yay everybody's happy right cool
[Music]
um but still like what I wanted to
achieve is having a different system or
a different way of looking at the
problem so yeah that that's basically
what the model does uh we'll we'll see
if we can improve that um yeah so
ranking how we can use that for ranking
so the main thing is now we have
posteriors so posterior distribution so
we can use that um I'm focusing here on
a single week but we can do that for for
every um we of back test and and
comparing one of the the actual ranking
which is the rank column um to what we
will get if we rank with the median of
the ability so this is the core ability
um the right column and then we have the
rank based on that and it's kind of
similar the top 10 is kind of similar
it's shuffled in different ways uh there
are a couple of outliers and then we do
that we can do that for every single
surface there the outliers are still
there and like the main difference is
Casper rud like he number four in the
world ranking but like the model would
say something else and it's because it's
2022 was amazing year and 2023 is not
going so well uh due to many reasons but
the model captures that very early in so
now if next week there is a there is a
tournament we wouldn't place that as a
seated player right so that that's what
the premise was of the talk um another
way of com comparing ranking is like
over time on the left you can see uh the
actual ranking of the top four players
layer of the model and you can see it's
kind of static yeah it's it's not very I
don't know it doesn't update very soon
it's static it's it's there while on the
right it's it's the posterior ability
the core ability and it looks like a
actual process maybe Gan process or
something so yeah it's uh way more
Dynamic yeah cool application yay why
Bion there is the big debate ban again
entist I don't want I don't want any
anym anymore at all uh but what is cool
is that again we have posteriors we have
distribution so what we can do is to use
them um we can do all the prescriptive
analysis and analytics with that uh
these are word number one against word
number three and we take the probability
of one beating the other on two surfaces
and well we have diff quite quite the
substantial difference but as you can
see the the distribution is very wide
like from 10% to to 90% so not much
indication it's reasonable it's War
number one against War number three if
we go with jovic war number two with the
model and against rude like we can see
that like all the density is above 50%
so we are pretty sure
that that will be the case in a match uh
in both surfaces like but through these
uh clay specialist so has 5% more with
respect the the hard cord so that's that
uh okay cool was a fun weekend raining
inin uh where to go from here so there
are a lot of stuff that can be model in
addition to that uh other factors such
as fatigue um you can include other
priors so as I said there are a lot of
upsets in tenis so you could consider
more bu prior more wirers for example
student distribution as uh f as a prior
um different model architecture
hierarchical model like here I have a
parameter not shared anywhere but you
can do that uh agion processes uh as as
we saw like the ability looks like a
process in a way uh extend period of
analysis please
somebody my laptop was burning all the
time while sampling and compare with
other models so elating is another way
of doing that it's it's fre
I don't know if there is a ban version
but there is for sure a frequency
version that can do that and other
application so you can apply that first
you can extend to draws and ties so for
example football and chesses
and I also learned that you can extend
to for llms prompt to to evaluate them
uh didn't know that but apparently you
can and to conclude I aan joke thought
about it long time thought it was funny
but I told them to a few friends and now
I'm sure that it's not well that's
it